so you know I've been in game for 20 odd
years and when I studied in games we
didn't trust see we were performance
sensitive parts an assembler and then we
moved on to not trusting C++ and writing
in C and then we moved on to not
trusting STL and writing a C++ and now
we're somewhere around there and we're
not trusting modern C++ very much and
we're writing in C++ so you know there's
gonna be nothing new in this for this
crowd but this is kind of like you might
talk to people who are skeptical about
modern C++ because this is a common kind
of thing that people say in fact this is
common about more than modern C++ this
is people say this about things like
unit tests or or strong static types or
collaboration being these people still
have a problem which is that they have
to hire C++ programmers and today that
means hiring modern C++ programmers so
here is my kind of standardized
guaranteed seven features plus or minus
two of modern C++ that that that you can
adopted a piecemeal and the code base
which isn't modern which is still 90 803
and nobody should complain about them
the first one of course is override this
if you do nothing else do this tell
people because it finds real bugs
I found a four year old bug in my code
base because of this you know just just
as you touch code just add override to
your virtual functions then the compiler
says doesn't override anything you're
like what and then you hit get blame and
you're like oh
it happens it happens alright number two
underlying types freedoms brilliant you
know we all like enums you don't have to
do kind of bit with forcing values
anymore you can do forward declarations
this helps with serialization there's
nothing not to like and it works on
old-style enums as well as new style
scope denotes nobody has any complaints
about that this one using over type def
it's one character few at the type I
never you know despite being a super
program maybe twenty years I never found
type def straightforward or evil and
these days function pointers in
particular I just used actually trading
with turn type for that cuz I think of
an auto star as a thing that means we
did the function this is an interesting
one
do you fault member initialization
because this in a language that actually
is fast becoming optimization required
this can improve debug performance I
found and and if you go to those cobalt
links you'll see exactly how there's no
enough time in this likely talk so you
know so games programmers debug
performance is still important so this
can actually help and there's lots of
structs scared around the code that kind
of just hang out there and just have
default constructors just to set the
values so this helps with actually debug
performance sometimes here's another
easy one that no one should be able to
complain about just of course we all
know this take your old non call people
classes and make them deleted special
member functions turn the link error
into a more understandable compiler
number six is a very simple recipe many
code bases that i've encountered have
this length of define x is actually
better be an array there or you'd be in
trouble
of course c / plus eleven only suitable
eleven concepts were required on that
one and it's safe so even if you don't
want to dive into context for usage as a
whole yet will change every code base as
a whole this is a good thing to tell
people it's extra type safety for no
cost so it's just a simple recipe they
can apply and number seven explicit bull
so get rid of safe ball idiom
another great thing take out all that
hacky stuff with the pointers to member
functions and internal types and you get
just explicit operator ball and it does
it gives you ball where you want it it
doesn't give you a ball we don't want it
so there's a plus or minus two here if
they're lapping this stuff up you know
you might move on to say well get rid of
your old hacky static assert using your
size of trickery because that's in the
language now and you can tell them that
compiles faster because of it probably
and it's certainly less code to maintain
and if they're really liking modern C++
then my number one thing is chrono this
really improved code bases I put it on
it has the great advantage that you can
apply it piecemeal and how would this
answering questions on Stack Overflow
anything you have bad these are probably
already answered so so this is the list
you know if you talk to people who are
skeptical about more than C++ my thought
is you can tell them any of these and
there's pretty much no downside and they
don't have to like change up the whole
code base they don't have to kind of do
anything new they can just do what
they're doing but these will make their
life better thank you very much
[Applause]